As you can see, there is a clear divide between good and evil.
Villains are usually depicted as unappealing, scary and old,...
...draped in shadows and dark colors.
They're meant to be identified as evil, which means that they can never be cute.
The word "kawaii" is widely used to describe the quality of being like a child,...
...which means that you can be cute and lazy at the same time.
Yeah, a kawaii is a fascinating idea to me.
It's a very vulnerable kind of cute.
It's like, you're so cute that you make people want to take care of you.
The term emerged in the 1970s and became a big part of Japanese culture.
It was shown through fashion, handwriting and even behavior.